all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i don't know if you guys have
seen but there was a massive and insane
plot leak for doctor strange 2 that came
out recently from a guy over at reddit
my time to shine hello right apparently
they've released a bunch of information
from the mcu before which is proved to
be accurate so a lot of people are just
kind of like this is probably solid and
given the nature of the information in
the leak
it sounds legit right it sounds like it
could actually happen okay so check this
out check this out here's the idea
behind the information that they leaked
where previous leaks have stated that
the main villain is like schumacher and
shumagorath is trying to catch america
chavez for whatever reason
this really seems to just kind of leave
that out and instead america chavez is
trying to escape wanda and the question
is why because wanda cannot actually
leave the universe wanda can only send
her consciousness into the multiverse
and the goal of wanda is to basically
possess or to take control of america
chavez so that she can jump through the
multiverse now whether or not this is so
wanda can just take the powers away from
erika chavez or simply just use her
consciousness to possess the body of
america chavez are things that are just
not really explained here now the other
part of this leak is that america chavez
will actually be accompanied by strange
over the course of this process whether
or not they're trying to find a safe
universe or whether they're simply
trying to find a place for her to hide
or strange is teaching her how to shield
her mind and they're on the run from
wanda while we're doing it that's not
really specified but the cool thing here
is that apparently both america chavez
and steven strange are going to meet a
variant of baron mordo from an alternate
reality and baron murdo will initially
approach them as a friend and then
capture them and the reason why is
because he's going to take them before
professor x who is basically a member of
the illuminati but the difference here
is that unlike being a group that exists
in every single universe and they serve
to safeguard the earth from whatever
threats may be out there they're
actually a multiversal peacekeeping
force something similar to the tva but
not in the exact same capacity
especially considering that as we're
aware right now the tva is ruled by kane
the conqueror now there's grounds for
this i've never seen the illuminati used
in this capacity before which is really
really cool normally when it comes to
like multiversal peacekeeping forces you
have like the omniversal development
court the captain britain core altezza
the custodian of the multiverse you've
got like the living tribunal you've got
scathing the approver you have all these
different beings out there right the
fulcrum and so on and so forth but we've
never really seen this group used in
that capacity now following that
following the idea of mordo snatching up
steven strange and america chavez and
bringing them to the group a couple
things are going to happen one of which
we kind of have to assume and the other
is stated in this leak the thing that we
have to assume is that most likely
stephen strange and america chavez are
going to plead their case and basically
they'll come out on top they'll say okay
most likely doctor strange will read
their minds and then verify that they're
actually telling the truth the thing
that was thrown out there in the leak is
that because wanda is trying to track
down american chavez she's gonna get
into a fight with professor x they're
gonna end up being in like a telepathic
battle which is amazing because we've
seen that happen with professor x so
many times before here's the thing
professor x does this kind of stuff all
the time and it comes in different
circumstances right one of the most
notable instances was when storm the
x-men who can control the weather when
she was a little girl and she was in
cairo egypt and she pickpocketed
professor x only to find out she was
doing it at the hands of a guy named
amal farooq you guys know him from the
legion tv series as the shadow king and
the idea is that the shadow king had
basically brought people to work under
him and so when prefecture x realized
the storm was being manipulated he
entered into like this tavern and him
and the shadow king engaged in a psychic
battle in charles xavier 1. we've seen
instances when jean grey was first
brought into the x-men because her
telepathy was beyond her ability to
control charles xavier put up mental
blocks around her mind so she couldn't
use her telepathy eventually she
graduated to the point that she could
and those mental blocks were slowly
released but we've seen this kind of
thing happen right the astral plane is
most likely where that battle would take
place because you're talking about the
consciousness of wanda as opposed to the
physical form of wanda and if that
happens that's gonna be an amazing
battle because the astral plane doesn't
have a physical form i mean it kind of
does but it kind of doesn't but it's
where people go to fight when they have
like telepathic battles and so you could
see just some craziness unfold in this
conflict right that like charles xavier
is just like some great big huge battle
knight and then like wanda is like a
giant dragon and then they switch and
then wanda becomes something else and he
becomes something else there's no limit
to the kind of stuff you could see in
terms of what form their astral
projections take now the other part of
this leak is that the illuminati has
more members and some of them are going
to die at the hands of wanda but for the
most part the entire roster has been
thrown out there save for one guy
apparently you're gonna actually have
captain marvel but it's not gonna be
carol danvers it's actually gonna be
monaco rambo you guys know her from one
division the other person listed here is
captain carter which really makes sense
giving the way the ending of the what if
series for episode number one concluded
i mean she did come back but we don't
know what she was doing between the time
she went through the portal and the time
she returned through the portal it could
be that she ran into the illuminati and
for whatever reason they brought her
onto the team whatever the case happens
to be just because of the power she
possessed and like destroying that
demonic entity or because she has a lot
of conviction and courage who really
knows right i mean quite literally she
pushed the thing to the portal
disappeared for like decades then
returned and the episode ended and that
was it right it'd be a great way to kind
of fill in the gaps going on there the
final member of the illuminati team we
don't know like apparently it's just
kind of a guessing game and rumors
abound as to who this might be i mean as
you all can imagine the number one guest
is an alternate reality version of tony
stark
everybody wants to see robert downey jr
come back it would be cool it'd be
pretty amazing one of the other theories
going on out there depending on what
they end up doing with black panther 2
is that it could actually be shuri who
became black panther in an alternate
universe instead of her brother t'challa
now this might strike a different kind
of chord depending on how much of a fan
you are some people might take that as
an insult to the memory of chadwick
boseman others might celebrate it and
say hey that would be a cool story they
should make a what-if episode based on
that but whatever the case happens to be
the missing member we don't know who
that is right so i'm curious who are
your thoughts on who the missing member
of the illuminati team might be right
let me know down in the comments section
who you think that person is but i gotta
tell you guys this is probably one of
the most detailed leaks to ever come out
really in a long
long time i gotta be honest with you
guys i'm excited about this man like
even if not all of this pans out i think
it's a genius idea i think it's a great
idea i think this also really goes to
the fact that like everything is
changing when it comes to the mcu the
multiverse and all that kind of stuff
right the mcu has its own multiverse
marvel comics has its own multiverse
right new multiverse new rules it's a
whole different set of standards now so
having said that based on these leaks if
they're any ounce true
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section let me know what
you guys think about all this do you
think it's true are you kind of like
i mean it's cool but it's a little far
fetched right what do you disagree with
about these leaks let me know down in
the comment section but thank you guys
for watching this is awesome and i will
catch you all later peace